PROFESSOR: The
point of switching
from relational language to
graph theoretical language
is really so that we can talk
about paths and connections.
So let's look at the topic of
graph connectivity in general.
Two vertices in a simple
graph, or for that matter,
a directed graph, are said
to be connected if and only
if there's a path between them.
In a directed graph, the
path would have a direction.
In a simple graph, paths
don't have direction.
So a is connected to b if and
only if b is connected to a.
It's a symmetric relation.
So two vertices are
connected if and only
if there's a path between them.
That's equivalent, of
course, to saying if and only
if there's a walk between them.
We include length 0
paths and length 0 walks,
so every vertex is considered
to be connected to itself.
A whole graph is said to be
connected if all of its vertex
are connected to each other.
So every graph you
can think of as
broken up into the mutually
connected pieces, or subgraphs,
which are called its
connected components.
So let's look at
a simple example.
Let's look at the connections
between MIT buildings,
where we draw an edge between
building 10 and building 13
if there's a door between them
or a corridor or between them.
So there's a corridor between
building 10 and building 4,
but not between building
10 and building 12.
To get to 12, you
have to go through 4.
That's the main building numbers
off the MIT Infinite Corridor.
East campus, of course,
isn't connected to anything,
so it's a single,
isolated vertex.
And then there's the medical
center in E17 and E25,
which are a sequence of four
buildings that are connected
as indicated, but not
connected at all to east campus
or the Infinite
Corridor, that is,
you have to go outside
to get from east campus
to the Infinite Corridor or
from the Infinite Corridor
to the medical center.
Unless you sneak through the
basement and another restricted
areas.
So this is one graph.
It's not three graphs.
This is one graph
which has three parts,
and so it has three
connected components.
In general, the more
connected components
a graph has, the
more broken up it
is, and that's a
way to remember it.
The formal definition of
the connected component
of a vertex, v, is simply
all of the vertices, w,
that are connected
to v. And if you
look at these
connected components,
they've defined an equivalence
relation on the vertices,
of course, because a
connected component is a block
of the equivalence relation.
It's a block of the
partition associated
with the equivalence relation.
Another way to define this,
the set of w that are connected
to v, is simply it's
taking the image of v
under the greater than or
equal to 0 walk relation.
E star is our notation
for the walk relation
in the graph whose edges are
E, including walks of length 0.
So a graph is connected then
means it really has only one
connected component.